[Music]
[Applause]
chris sims former quarterback pro
football talk live co-host joins us on
the program give the audience the
factors that went into your mock draft
how do you come up with your mock draft
well i try to do it a little bit out of
just hey team need what makes sense you
know doing that also listen
realistically going about what i'm
hearing through the nfl as well so if i
get to a team and have no inkling or
feel for what they're going to do
i try to you know then go to my board
and realize okay what is what do they
need what's the positions what's the
value of some of the guys there and i do
it that way you know but even with that
i don't necessarily say
like totally true to my board like for
for my money christian watson from north
dakota state he's the number two
receiver in the draft for me there's no
talking me off that ledge but i know i'm
kind of in the minority in the nfl that
way so at that time i also realized that
he probably won't be the second guy off
the board so i use a little common sense
with what i know and hear around the nfl
too so it's a little combination of
things dan all together okay so is this
your your
uh predictions
is that what it is okay it is the
predictions to a degree there's to a
degree now listen i'd love to change
pick number one right now i did this
over the weekend i made it aidan
hutchinson i realized there was the
rumors of trayvon walker and the tackle
conversation and all that but that's
what i kind of find interesting about
this year's draft without a big-time
quarterback well it to me the people i
know in the nfl it kind of sounds like
doug peterson's winning the war down
there that tackle could be a very real
thing at one and that'll throw the top
five into a frenzy a little bit now with
hutchinson and walker being there and
some of the other players and what
happens so i'm excited to see how that
kind of shakes out okay paulie has a bet
with one of our listeners
top 13 picks
that there will be at least one
quarterback
okay paulie looked at your mock draft
and i started to get nervous yeah
because yes paulie i would say that a
month ago i felt really good about my
bet and then in the past two weeks the
mock draft's been trending that it's hot
takes coming down this road um the mock
draft's been trending that no
quarterback goes in the top 15. i would
say over the past two weeks
right
yeah i i i have a hard time seeing it
here's here's how i at least boil it
down you know at six with carolina hey
we know they need a quarterback
i it's matt rule his butt is on the hot
seat i just can't imagine the coaching
staff wanting to go that oh it's a do or
die year and we're going to break in a
rookie quarterback maybe david tepper
you know jumps in and says no i'm the
owner and we're taking the act but i
don't expect that but doesn't that buy
you some time i know the the the bears
tried to do that right justin
yes right no you're right there is the
political play of wait look at i had the
rookie quarterback and we had a little
success so keep me here because we're
building something you know matt nagy
with his situation i can understand them
doing that a little bit they were the
playoffs two or three years maybe he
thought he had a little more security
than he really did this one i don't
think there's much security it's like
put up or shut up time is there a team
that should take a quarterback in the
first three eight so i was getting there
eight atlanta is definitely the team i
look at to go uh
will they get it on a malik willis i
don't think they're gonna be in the
kenny pickett thing i just again looking
at their offense arthur smith what they
do they want play action pass and they
want to strike down field with a big arm
to me that is corral or malik willis so
i look at them as eight to go oh that
could be the team that
helps out you know paulie's bet there to
to make sure the quarterback goes into
the top 13. but i think it's dicey at
this point i do
how does debo samuel affect the draft
i i don't think it's going to affect it
a whole lot for two reasons i think the
49ers are going to go down swinging as
far as trying to salvage the
relationship with debo samuel he's too
important to their football team it's
different than devonta adams and tyree
kill you know the the the packers and
the chiefs already beared the fruits of
all the labor and the talent they had to
give the 49ers got a steal by drafting
this guy in the second round they know
that and he's just about to hit the
prime of his career
and they got a quarterback that we know
is raw
and you want to get things smoothly
who's going to make things easier than
oh here's a little touch pass the demo
samuel look i'm one for one for 70 yards
coach this is amazing so that's where i
think like i don't see that happening
anytime soon at least not before the
draft i think this uh 49ers will exhaust
all options to make that right why do
you see one out
i i would love to know that too it's the
biggest i i have everybody in football
texting me wondering why because you
know of course i'm friends with kyle
shanahan so everybody thinks i have
those answers i don't i'd love to know
i'm not lying then i'm calling i've been
calling and texting everybody on earth
trying to find out well why don't you
call or text kyle shanahan because he
ain't going to tell me he doesn't want
to tell me he doesn't it's not going to
happen and i'm not going to put him in
that situation i know i you know i just
know and i know enough by i text other
people out there in san francisco to
where i know it's it's delicate that's
the word that was thrown out to me a few
times i have heard the living in
california thing there is some reality
to that i also have heard
from somebody connected to debo samuel's
side that it did bother them that nick
bose's contract was kind of at the
forefront of the 49ers organization over
his it's the only two things that i have
had any talk or chatter about so i'm
kind of in the dark like the rest of uh
all of us and just i'm dying to know too
dan
tyreek hill though kind of changed the
whole world uh of the receiving world
like i thought we would get
i thought tj watt would be the first
non-quarterback to get 30 million
dollars
a year and tyree kill kind of knocked on
the door with that
and you know i just wonder what position
is going to be that that first 30
million dollar a year
position other than a quarterback
i i i mean i think you're you're on to
it it's gonna be that pass rusher or
maybe it will be debo samuel uh there's
a lot of talk out there the debut wants
to be the highest non-paid quarterback
out there and you know he's he's
extremely talented he's
definitely in the conversation for the
best receiver in football he's the
number one weapon in football they don't
throw the ball down the field all that
much and he's still leading the league
in average yards per catch that just
tells you what he is he makes a whole
lot of chicken salad out of chicken you
know what there and two dan you know we
talked to he's hitting the prime of his
career to me that's where the price tag
is more expensive for debo samuel than
it is for tyree kill or devonte adams i
i think like if you're gonna make a
trade for debo you know you can look at
tyrique and devonte adams and go okay
now what are we gonna add on top of that
because i don't think it's gonna happen
unless it's something like that that
really opens the 49ers eyes and and and
uh gets them to make that kind of move
well the dolphins had to give up draft
picks for tyreek hill you know the
raiders got devonte adams you know and
and so
that's what i think is interesting that
you you can get debo sammy you're gonna
have to pay for debo samuel in more ways
than one draft picks and also the salary
is that is there a player that you
absolutely love in this draft
well yeah there there's a few that i
absolutely love just one in five years
we're talking about this player
oh well
i think the guy that i love the most and
here's another interesting tidbit to me
in the top ten i mean i'll just i'll
throw jamison williams out there you
know of course i love the guys at the
top of the draft they're really good the
both tackles and and the two pass
rushers they're they're awesome and i
think they're slam dunk you know pro
bowl starting for your team high level
players for a long time jameson williams
is the guy i look at to go
this is this could be the next superstar
wide receiver he can do you know all
that you ask of a receiver and then some
but coming from the entry though right i
would take him you know like again if
i'm atlanta at eight or i'm at the jets
at 10
it's not about week two or three of the
2022 season it's about week 12 of the
22-2 season and then going into the
future that way and to me he is uh the
game breaker he's every bit as good as
devonta smith was last year dan he's
every bit and in some ways i really
think he's probably better and he's
worthy of i think a top five pick if he
didn't have the acl but if i'm a team
that's looking receiver in top 10 i'm
taking him baker mayfield status
uh how much is that contingent on what
happens in the draft
um i don't think it's gonna matter
before the draft i think it's gonna be
one of those after the draft's over okay
we're carolina we're the seattle
seahawks did we do anything in you know
any of the first three rounds to get a
quarterback to think that helps us for
the future okay no wait we didn't let's
call baker up and let's get him in here
and have him compete with sam darnold or
drew lockup and i think that's really
how i kind of envision it playing out i
do you know so that that's yeah it's
interesting but the options out there
right now we're talking about garoppolo
and baker mayfield that's all there is
to it so i think that's the teams or the
the names you're going to hear the most
after this draft is all over it just
feels like there's no market for jimmy
garoppolo that the niners hope to get a
couple of second round picks for him and
coming off surgery i got
my keys middle aged quarterback wise and
right expensive i i i just
like i'd much rather take my chance on a
a rookie quarterback than i would jimmy
garoppolo
i i i don't disagree with that statement
at all dan and i i'd rather take my
chance on baker mayfield too you know
there's there's high end talent there
still with baker mayfield garoppolo you
know decision making questionable oh
wait the 49ers have been trying to get
rid of them for three years now
basically that would scare the hell out
of me too trade away two second round
picks wait he's not starting for you
guys this year why would i trade that
are you really gonna do that and keep
them there all season i just i have a
hard time with all of that and then i i
do question even how good he is as a
player i know he's a starter but he's to
me nowhere near the top half of the
league he's around that 20 range he's
been with mcdaniels and shanahan i mean
two guys that can just deliver plays dan
you could go in some games and have a
good quarterback rating playing for
those guys so that that's that's where i
i would understand those questions
around the nfl about jimmy g
what do you see the rams and chargers
needing
oh
you know uh the the rams are interesting
i mean they've they've killed the middle
part of the draft really i can see
o-line being a thing for them you know
you know no whitworth
they got some guys they're going to be
free agents their other right tackle
havenstein their o-line's not great to
begin with so i could see that
corner being two positions that they
kind of maybe addressed they lost darius
williams right in free agency i believe
it was jacksonville off the top of my
head uh they'd be that would be kind of
where i'd look at for them maybe even no
i would say that's about it but they're
amazing at the middle part of the draft
people got to start giving them a little
more credit for what they do you look at
their team at superstars and a bunch of
third and fourth and fifth round picks
that's make up their starting team it's
pretty amazing that way who was the
other team you asked me about chargers
the chargers
i got them going the big defensive
tackle from connecticut at pick 8 17.
uh they are another team that could
maybe be in the offensive line market
they did some things in free agency and
i think they're like trey pipkins that
where they might look at a lineman later
on second third round but the worst run
defense in football
brandon state are one of the worst
brandon staley he's from vic fangio that
scheme is three four-ish they usually
like a few bodies like akeem hicks or
somebody in the middle and that's kind
of who this kid is from connecticut
travis jones i could see them going
there in the first round do you remember
your draft profile
the negative things and how that
affected you or did it affect you
um yeah i mean it affected me i mean it
it it affected me in the fact that i i
wanted to prove it wrong i didn't think
it was fair necessarily uh but yeah my i
think the biggest thing was me is i
couldn't win the big game right you know
that was my it couldn't be in oklahoma
we played in the big 12 championship my
junior year and played a colorado team
that we were better than and i pissed
down my leg and threw three
interceptions in the first half so i you
know i had to deal with that not
literally well no maybe maybe there's a
few drips and drops there but no not
literally okay but do the do the gms and
coaches ask you about that uh prior to
the draft about not being able to didn't
oh they didn't no okay i know that's
that's what i always i always was
waiting to get that you know and i
always wanted to i would but nobody ever
asked me and then i'd go home and you
know my agent would talk to me and go
yeah that's kind of what teams you're
worried about you know and i wanna i was
always dying for somebody to like hey
let's turn on the oklahoma game and i
want to go yeah let's turn it on so i
can show you it's a team sport and damn
we couldn't run nobody's open
i mean but it was all my fault guys i
couldn't win the big game i mean that's
that's what yeah but then it would be a
red flag sims
teammates right right sims is a jerk and
he's taking notes
yeah so i'd have to find the right sweet
spot there to blame myself and and show
a little reality too well we love uh
your mock draft i take uh
uh great solace in reading that and uh
getting a better understanding there
thanks man you know the other two i just
want to jump on here too you know i love
both georgia d tackles and i got them
going at nine and ten to me they're like
devante wyatt's everybody's good every
bit as good as quinn and williams was
coming out in the draft at the number
three pick a few years ago but the two
guys that can throw a curve into all
this dan i wouldn't touch them in the
top ten
as kavon thibodeaux or derek stingley jr
that to me is going to be the other one
there where i feel like yeah there's a
group of teams in football that think
they're awesome and then i think there's
a group of teams in football that go i
wouldn't touch them with a 10-foot pole
and i that i'll be interested to see how
that shakes out in the in the first
round too thibodeaux reminds me
you know when dion jordan came out we're
like oh my god this guy's unbelievable
and then you realize
he wasn't unbelievable he could get
pushed around a little bit there no
doubt no doubt
yeah good player no never should have
been in the first round conversation
and you know clearly the fifth or sixth
best r edge rusher to me you know i look
at him at a guy that really
realistically i think he should go in
the end of the first round but i think
because of some of the hype and that and
some teams probably do i and the beauty
the beholder he'll probably go before
that thank you bud always great to talk
to you we appreciate you joining us
say hi to the guys
chris sims pro football talk live
co-host and uh former nfl quarterback